potential clincher in game three
as the atlanta braves have a two-nothing
lead on the miami marlins
another man making his playoff debut
kyle wright the 25 year old from alabama
brian anderson in the cleanup spot here
it is
and it swung on and missed slider on the
outside corner or was it a change up i
thought it was a change-up boy it's a
beauty
two k's for right two down to the inning
and next up is the dh garrett cooper
a little spin on that one as it hit the
deck a good snare by
right and he works out of a jam in his
playoff debut
and the bases are loaded for adam duvall
one two
got him with a hundred up high duvall
goes down swinging
and a massive first out for sanchez to
get here in the second
marquess might just be looking for one
pitch right i got two oh if i get it
i'll swing if not i'm
taken and he swings and sends it to left
dickerson charging
and he made the catch what a play to
save a run
that was a change that was the change up
down the way i was i was looking for
and look at dickerson just keeping it
off the deck my goodness what a play
base is still loaded for austin riley
and a one-two to riley
on the ground to short rojas has it the
flip to second
in time and sixto sanchez
pulls a rabbit out of the hat and
advancing to third now is chisholm with
two out chad wallach of the
light-hitting catcher is coming up next
for miami 0-2 on wallock
and here it comes from wright swinging a
foul tip
nope in the dirt and picked up by the
catcher darnell who'll throw him out at
first base
good low breaking ball from right that's
his third strikeout
and he works around a lead-off walk in
the second freeman runner at second and
nobody out
swings away over the shortstop rojas
dickerson gets to it fast and acuna will
hold up at third
but there is the first base hit of the
series for freddie freeman and now you
got the nl
home run and rbi leader in marcelo zuno
with two on and nobody out
first pitch swinging and marcelo zuna
gives the braves the lead
acuna scores and it's one nothing
atlanta in game three
now darno in the air right center field
sierra and birdie ranging back and it's
off the wall
freeman will score ozuna will score
travis
darno continues to smoke here in houston
it's three-nothing atlanta a huge huge
hit
another one for travis darneau lacuna he
hates it he's so excited
keep throwing at me i'll keep scoring
runs guys now here's dansby swanson who
walked his first trip back in the second
off the fists charging in birdie
underneath it darnow's gonna take off
here's the throw from birdie
it'll be cut off and it's four to
nothing atlanta a sacrifice fly
for swanson the marlins now have two on
with nobody out and the heart of the
order coming up
2-2 pitch swinging a miss beautiful
breaking ball down and there's the first
down to the bottom half of the third
good pitch by right
well this is the exact same about
anderson had his first time up with
first and second one out
yep went back to it and he went around
back-to-back strikeouts for kyle wright
with two on
now two away another slider anderson
just cannot lay off of it jazz chisholm
with the bases loaded and two out
and the 1-0 on the way is pulled sharply
on the ground to the right side fielded
by all these from the outfield grass he
throws him out
wow that was a bullet off the bat of
chisholm toward the hole right side but
ozzy
angling back into the outfield grass
snagged it spun around and threw him out
so kyle right into and out of a major
jam in the third no runs one hit
three left freeman at the plate there's
freeman
first pitch swinging smacks it towards
the gap in left center
sierra has some trouble with it that
might let acuna score
he's on his way home and it's five to
nothing atlanta but braves off to a
red-hot start
here in game three looking to clinch
swanson with a man in scoring position
the other way to right that'll get down
in front of birdie for a base hit
albie's is getting the wave
the throw cut off by aguilar his relay
gets away
nice bare hand by rogers to snare that
off the back wall
and that holds swanson at first but it's
an rbi to drive in all these
and it's a six nothing atlanta lead in
the fifth next step for the braves adam
duvall
that's golden high fly ball left center
field
deep back toward the wall that ball is
off the fence
hansby running wide open from the crack
of the bat coming to the plate he's
going to score
slides across seven to nothing braves on
an rbi double
by adam duvall so brian snitker going to
stick with the
25 year old in his playoff debut and let
him try to maybe finish out six before
turning it over
3-2 to cooper is back to the mound
kyle wright with the second out walking
a ground out for
jazz chisholm and is on the ground to
second
and aldi's look at him run wow he is
fast right
but a one two three sixth inning
travis darno
towards left center field coming on is
brynson and he makes a great catch to
end the inning nice play lewis brinson
keeps the braves off the board
brian anderson up next for the marlins
oh for three with two strikeouts in the
ground out
anderson hits one hard to left field on
his horse duval to the warning track
makes a running catch
so loud contact to left but adam duvall
with a perfect route
and he runs down the drive by anderson
no runs one hit
one man left we have finished eight
innings in houston with the braves
leading the marlins
seven to nothing and it'll be shane
green
to try to get the final three outs for
the atlanta braves
here's matt joyce off the bench to hit
in the eight spot
last chance for the marlins 1-1 hammered
to right
poche is over and he makes the catch and
for the first time in 19 years
the atlanta braves have punched their
ticket to the national league
championship series
what a performance by swanson and darno
in particular
and the atlanta braves
advance to baseball's final four
they'll await the dodgers or the padres